hey Theo hey Brennan I got a debate club
for you
my girlfriend is a liberal and I am a
conservative do you think it will work
or do you think we should just give up
we getting arguments all the time over
politics and I love her and we get along
great most of the time but I don't know
I'm just wondering your thoughts on it
yeah so let's say fire Nick at the end I
got a monster energy I don't think the
[ __ ] uh bro he's had to listen to a
liberal for years he said there's three
burnt some let's forget I did that no
it's okay it's a good question man
that'd be tough man like my dad so
scared this cope it's tough for this
Trump stuff I mean him I mean we can't
we can't talk politics Iturbi problem
but I tried to just stay away from it
I can't mention it you need him go rap
war man he kicks your ass well I just
keep sent him fat I just keep dropping
fats on his ass you know I think it's
hard to deal what's hard to deal with
anybody that's extreme I find it's hard
to deal with anybody that's extreme one
way or the other from me so I find it
hard to do it like I prom my prom it's
not my problem like let's say feel was
super whatever again some I believed
they didn't you don't have to not like
the person who gives a [ __ ] yeah said
it's Theo you know I don't care what he
believes in politics that's fine you
have to hate so much other political
views yes some people won't like
somebody because of their political
views like I don't get that part like up
here yeah I have bigger I just have you
know bigger Fister if I just have more
things that are more important but
politics have always been one of those
things they say you don't talk about it
you know you know which is weird to me
because it's like if you if you vote fit
like ask my dad when Hillary and Trump
were vote I want who'd you vote for us
come on that's personally okay what is
it so personal top on you voted for and
why well now you're starting the
conversations with you start in the
argument
we're on board we're on board we're on
the same page until all that stuff
happened you starting this [ __ ] but see
how fired up people get yeah when you're
their own son and you try to ruin their
lives by continually start you know but
if that's if you should if you're super
strong minded in politics your thing and
your girls against it ain't gonna work
that's tidy I think it can be tough
wouldn't a girl fight over flamin hot
cheetos little own politics you know me
if politics your thing it's not gonna
work man
Bernie you always fight over food oh
yeah you are right
yeah very true dude you're instigating
it come on over dog you I went to my
barber that Goldie locks you up ya wit I
told hit up my barber it's like a
speakeasy yeah coming you back like that
green wall yeah I told you the English
yeah very little you Scott you get a
dangle bueno bueno there's your pictures
hair vatos baby show off pictures a lot
of tried to scroll here they [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up
yeah every Walia that exist and I saw
that that's not a green wall what'd the
guy look like that did your hair short
little Mexican dude word who's a G was
he yeah and not what age group was he
and you think it's tough to tell it's
tough to tell they don't look very
similar yeah
it's felt did he take a long thought was
it my guy it was he he goes Brent
Brendan sent you time to bully listen to
your [ __ ] we don't talk yeah what do
you guys think about this what do you
think cuz it is interesting man if
you're if you're and God bless this
fella that sent this and he's obviously
hiding in the garage from his spouse at
the moment or she locked him in the
garage you could tell you know there's
only that one window in there with them
he had to be quiet yeah very quiet so it
looks like he's not even allowed to do
that much what do you what do you think
interesting I never had an issue with it
I'm pretty liberal but like my dad and
my mom are both conservatives my dad
loves Trout my mom hates Trump but
they're both Republican I mean I never
really had an issue with it because
politics don't really run our lives like
that yeah yeah same yeah whatever yeah
yeah as the great Bryan Callen said get
involved politics otherwise can get
involved with you what yeah you better
learn that [ __ ] they start taking on
your rights and chickens start getting
involved and know who to vote for and
[ __ ] some of this stuff I sit back and
then they control your control you know
I get I didn't understand your dude that
came in hot got it I understand well
some of the centrist shifts since your
censorship stuff does get real scary
oh you Tom taking us out of the
algorithm because you know my talk you
know Hannah's fine ass there you know
profanity yeah profanity
she can't cuss the first five minutes
and good can't stamp other people's
music a pair but waiter you have to be
liberally used taught me Twitter's only
it's really you know it really channels
more a lot more I don't even know if
liberally used to when I was young it
was just like Republican and Democrat
but now everything's so much more people
have so many more diverse thoughts
though to share the highway yeah scary
yeah that is scary man it's like comment
be [ __ ] down because people have to
live together that's the thing about the
country everybody you know we do all
have to live here so it's like and
everybody has the right to so it's it's
a real traffic jam bro I love you all
man and media covers it like team sports
like it's red vs. blue my team for you
your team like CNN and and ESPN they
look exactly the same they're the same
show and it's like it shouldn't be that
should be issues like yeah well CNN and
Fox you watch Fox News is like two one
will paint one patient one plate the
other and they're both extreme there's
no middle yeah so you can find your
confirmation whatever you're looking for
yeah that's a thing to now you can get
exactly what you want so there's really
fortifies how you feel I'm this guy but
I think mainstream media is the enemy of
the state
yeah
I agree that's a great movie by the way
well that when especially when the news
if you listen because the news can
really start to form how you how you
think to but remember the news is I'm
gonna fall any Bravo Sam Tripoli but
remember the news all they give a flying
[ __ ] about is rate oh yeah they make
them so since this whole death of that
that poor dude in Minneapolis have you
heard anything about koban your him time
I think about covin have you heard one
thing about kovin where's where's the
big grandpa what's this ramped up their
time out don't not be a Breitbart
another protest where's where's the
breakouts where's the Republican state
that opened up like Georgia and floored
all these states open where's where's
the Second Coming where's the heat wait
what are we talking about we are that I
know it's great it's a yeah it's crazy
to think how many places are making
money off of the riots and stuff making
money off of the part you know like
there's people like people are making
money off of George Floyd's death you
know what I'm saying like they're making
money off of it's crazy to think that
the news gets to make money off of that
what else you got yeah sorry give me
five yeah it's interesting though that
when people starts talking about this
kind of [ __ ] this that kind of [ __ ] this
new probably deals of every day it is
dinner imagine trying to do you know
finish off polish off a churro or
something with somebody or get yourself
a bowl of something you know a ham soup
or something you seem like you kind of
got it was slipper cut a ham into a bank
you know a damn so far a real suit like
you'd be angry pork chop my soup I'm
gonna turn it down I'm gonna push it
away the guy who had half of a fricken
farm on his plate in the beginning of
this thing and then we washed it down
with a doughnut from voodoo doughnuts
next your chocolate glaze and honors
Rosie good oh the best the best and what
is it real they don't have it is there's
a thick shot like I like a thick
chocolate glaze dog it's like right it's
perfect it's perfect right you brought
it no we were importantly yeah oh yeah
Portland that's where they started raise
God bro
we all got some ratchet in his mind so
what do we tell the guy King it I don't
even should he call quits or give it a
shot
it's gonna be a long road brother it's
be a long road yeah you can't I think
you can't control sometimes who you love
man I think sometimes like there will be
people and even though they have a ton
of things that bug you and stuff you
still love them I think sometimes you
can't control that kind of I'll be
open-minded man what'd he say he is a
conservative the side she's coming from
yeah they're gonna try to get us for a
hate crime bro just ain't the time to be
doing that kind of [ __ ] that they'll ya
hands up waterboarded yourself yeah I do
hands up don't sit bruh you got a chill
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]